(airplane sound)
- [Evan] What's up Believe Nation?
It's Evan, my one word is believe
and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves,
and my sincere hope is
that if you see in yourself
what I see in you, you'll be
able to change the planet.
I started the Believe Life Series
to help us learn a little
bit more about ourselves,
grow personally,
and ideally bring some of
what we learn about ourselves,
to our business to have more success.
So today we're going to learn
how to be optimistic in life.
(upbeat music)
(whimsical music)
- [Gary] I think the
biggest obstacle to success
is a lack of optimism.
I think the world like lacks optimism.
I think, you know, everyone's like,
"Your energy, your energy."
I've come to realize, it's just optimism,
just happy, just positive.
That's what it is.
(whimsical music)
- [Tony] Most of us have situations
where there are, for all of you listening,
a place where you have
some unfinished business.
(laughter)
- [Tim] That's the story
of my life, Tony. (laughs)
- [Tony] Okay well I do a
story of all our lives, right?
That's just being human, right?
But it's a place where
there's something that
you should have handled,
and you haven't handled,
with a person or situation,
it stresses you out.
And so what we tend to do
is focus on other stuff
'cuz we don't want to
have to deal with that
'cuz it's stressful, 'cuz
it's, you know, painful.
And so think of something
that on a zero to ten scale,
where ten is totally stressed
out and zero is not at all,
pick something that's unfinished business
in your business or personal life,
with something or someone,
and it's at least a seven,
eight, nine, or a ten.
Just so you can see
that this really works.
Now by the way, there are
hundreds of ways to do this.
I'm just going to give you this one,
'cuz we can do it in two minutes, alright.
So, I'm hoping, Tim do
you have one by chance?
- [Tim] I do.
- [Tony] Okay perfect.
Give me the topic of content,
no one else tells the content.
Alright. Everyone if you
would, just for a moment,
and I don't have any
music in the background
which I need to enhance this normally,
but let's just do it.
Put both your hands on your heart,
and physically breathe
deep into your heart.
And as you're breathing
deep in your heart,
feel the strength of you heart.
Feel the power of your heart.
Feel the beauty of your heart.
What are you proud, or grateful,
that your heart has guided you to do?
Or to give?
Or to feel?
Or to enjoy?
And feel of the strength of your heart,
breathe into it.
Feel the blood flow, the oxygen.
And feel grateful for your heart first.
Just think about it,
you didn't have to earn this heart,
it was given to you.
You didn't have to prove
your value or your worth,
you didn't have to accomplish anything.
Something loved you enough
to give you the gift of life.
As long as this heart is beating,
you have that gift,
and you live.
It beats 100,000 times a day.
It pumps blood through 60,000
miles of blood vessels,
they put 'em end to end,
they go around the world
twice at the equator.
That's what's inside every one of us.
And you don't have to think
about it, what a gift.
So as you breathe in your heart,
feeling your powerful heart,
I want you just for a moment,
we're going to think of three,
but just think first of
one event in your life,
one experience, one moment,
that you could feel so
grateful for if you wanted to,
a magic moment, a sacred moment,
a sexy moment, a beautiful
moment, a loving moment,
any moment that really you
could feel grateful for,
if you wanted to right now.
And then step into that
memory for a minute,
like step in your body
as if you were there.
See what you would have saw,
as if you're there.
Or hear what you'd hear, back then.
Breathe the way you were
breathing back then.
And if you fill up with
that sense of gratitude
for that moment,
how do you smile when you feel
so grateful or so thankful?
What's the look in your eyes?
How do you breathe?
Let's look in your face
when you feel really really grateful.
And just fill it up,
fill up with gratitude.
The reason we use gratitude, by the way,
the two emotions that mess
us up most is anger and fear.
And you can't be grateful
and angry simultaneously,
it's the antidote.
You can't be fearful and
angry simultaneously.
So fill up with gratitude,
now think of a second moment
you can feel truly grateful for,
and again breathe deep in your heart,
feel that power.
Just think of any other moment,
it could be from your
childhood or adulthood.
It could be last week, it could be today,
it could be ten years ago.
Any moment that you can
just truly feel like
that was the greatest, that was
magical, that was beautiful,
that's magnificent.
Something that gives you the feeling
of tremendous gratitude,
if you really focused on it.
Breathe it, feel it,
enjoy it.
Fill up with gratitude.
Then finally, think of a third moment
you can feel truly grateful for.
Step in it.
See it, feel it, be there.
Feel the gratitude.
What were you so grateful for?
What are you grateful for?
And then maybe throw one extra one in.
Think of a coincidence,
you know we all love
when life happens for us,
not to us.
We love coincidences 'cuz
we didn't do anything,
something happened for us.
You were going to do one thing
and you met somebody that you
developed a partnership with
or became a friend or a lover
or the love of your life.
Or maybe a business opportunity
came from a coincidence.
Or an insight came from a coincidence,
that's been so valuable in your life,
something you're grateful for.
What's the coincidence
that led to something
you're so grateful for?
And feel the gratitude for that.
And was it coincidence or were you guided?
Hmm.
Now as you breathe in your heart,
you've been doing this
for about two minutes.
Keep breathing, keep feeling it,
feeling grateful.
Let's use this state to
solve the problem state.
So the easy way to do that is,
is keep breathing in your heart
stay out of your head, in your heart,
and think of that situation
that's unfinished business,
that's stressed you out in the past.
But keep breathing in
this beautiful state,
and ask yourself this question:
ask yourself all I need to
focus on, in that situation,
all I need to focus on, all
I need to remember is what?
Your heart knows.
All I need to focus on,
all I need to remember,
all I need to do in
that situation, is what?
Your heart knows the answer.
All I need to focus on,
all I need to remember,
all I need to do is?
And then your heart
probably knows the answer.
I've done this a million times,
not every one of you, but a
normal room I'd have people say,
"Raise your hand if you got that answer."
98, 99% of people usually do,
even with this simple technique.
- [Leo] Optimism can be
stoked up, like a fire.
You know, you've got a campfire,
and it's kind of dying down,
and then you can blow air on it,
you can put some more kindling on it
and then it'll spark up, and flare up.
Well that's what you can
do with your optimism.
So right now maybe you're
just kind of feeling at a
at a baseline level,
where you're not too
pessimistic about your future,
but you're not too excited either.
So what I recommend you do,
is you do the following exercise.
I want you to take your journal,
piece of paper, something
where you can write,
and I want you to write out and list,
thirty things that
you're most excited about
in the next year, that you're going to do.
Thirty things that you're
super super excited about.
Maybe it's that vacation you want to take,
maybe it's that relationship
that you hope to get into.
Maybe it's that promotion at work
you know you're going to get.
Maybe it's having all your
credit card debts eliminated.
Maybe it's starting that
new business of yours,
or starting that dream project
or losing some weight.
Whatever it is, but start writing it down
and be as specific as possible.
Thirty things that you're excited about
achieving in the next year,
that really really motivate you.
Try to focus on the ones
that get you excited.
This is simple, this is all.
This is the whole exercise.
Sit down and actually do this,
take 20 minutes or whatever it takes you
to wite all this stuff out,
and notice how you feel.
Notice how you feel right now.
Notice how you feel before
you do the exercise,
and then I want you to notice how you feel
after you finish it.
If you're like me,
you're going to feel so
much more optimistic.
You're going to feel energized,
you're going to feel happy,
you're going to feel alive.
You're going to feel like
there's something to your life.
Because your future now is bright,
and it's right here before your eyes.
You've articulated it,
you've layed it out very clearly,
and it's right before you.
I recommend you do this
exercise more than once.
Do it right now
but also continue to do
it throughout your life.
Continue to do it, do it
at least once a month.
Do it even once a week because
it's going to get you connected back
to the stuff that's exciting to you.
And it's also going to, you know
you're mind's going to brainstorm
and come up with new
stuff to put on that list.
And you can be brainstorming
about what you're going to
be doing for the whole year,
but you can also localize it down
and you can shorten the timeframe
to something like the next month,
or even what you're going to be doing
over the next week or even today.
Even today you can do it.
Just like what are five things
you're going to be
excited about doing today?
If you do that exercise in the morning,
just for five minutes,
what are the five things
you're going to be excited
about doing today?
It'll probably even take you
just two minutes to do that.
You're going to feel you're
going to be much more excited
about your day,
and you're going to be
much more optimistic.
- [Michael] I was going through some stuff
and a woman said this to me, she was like,
"When you walk through a
doorway, say an affirmation."
And if you think about it,
think about how many doorways
you walk through in a day.
A bathroom door, your bedroom door,
a door of a building.
Your office door, in, out.
Every time you go in or out of a door,
you have to say something
positive about yourself.
Or something that you believe.
It's insane if you try it,
'cuz you end up saying like
400 things or 500 things a day.
And it's pretty incredible
how fast you see
the things that you say inside of you.
And that was something that
was really powerful for me.
- [Brian] I want to talk to you now
about the big difference
between optimists and pessimists
in life.
Between happy, excited, fulfilled people
and negative, tiring, depressed people.
Now everyone wants to
be physically healthy,
but it's important to want to
be mentally healthy as well.
The true measure of mental
fitness is how optimistic you are
about yourself and your life.
Now in order to become truly optimistic,
you must learn how to
control your thinking
in very specific ways,
so that you feel terrific about
yourself in your situation,
most of the time, no matter what happens.
There are three basic
differences in the reactions
of optimists and pessimists.
The first difference is that
the optimist sees a set back as temporary,
while the pessimist sees it as permanent.
The optimist sees an unfortunate event,
such as an order that falls through,
or a sales call that fails,
as a temporary event,
something that is limited in time
and that has no real impact on the future.
The pessimist on the other hand,
sees negative events as permanent,
as part of life and destiny.
The optimist makes a
mistake and brushes it off.
The pessimist makes a mistake
and considers that he or she
is not really good enough.
He or she is not competent,
he or she is not likable,
popular, or successful,
and becomes depressed,
becomes crizest by self pity,
sees themself as a victim,
and feels like quitting.
The second difference between
the optimist and the pessimist
is that the optimist sees
difficulties as specific,
while the pessimist
sees them as pervasive.
This is really important.
This means that when things
go wrong for the optimist,
he looks as the event
as an isolated incident,
largely disconnected from other things
that are going on in his life.
He deals with it and gets
busy, and puts it behind him.
For example, if something
you were counting on
failed to materialize, and
you interpret it to yourself
as being an unfortunate event,
but something that happens
in the course of life
and business, you know, stuff happens,
you would be reacting like an optimist.
The pessimist on the
other hand, is different.
The pessimist sees disappointments
as being pervasive,
"Oh, whoa me."
To him, those setbacks are indications
of a problem or shortcomings
that pervades every
area of his or her life.
They have this, "What's
the use?" attitude.
The third difference between
the optimist and pessimist
is that optimists see events as external,
while pessimists interpret
events as personal.
When things go wrong, the
optimist will stand to see
that set back is resulting
from external factors
over which one has little control.
For example, if the optimist
is cut off in traffic,
instead of getting angry or upset,
he will simply downgrade
the importance of the event
by saying something like, "Oh well,
I guess that person's
just having a bad day.
Or maybe he or she is in
a hurry to get to work.
Or something like that."
The pessimist on the other hand,
has a tendency to take
everything personally.
If the pessimist is cut off in traffic,
he or she will react as
though the other driver
has gotten up that morning,
and driven through traffic
and deliberately acted
to cut him off, to make
him upset and angry.
The hallmark of the fully mature,
fully functioning, self
actualizing personality,
is the ability to be
objective and unemotional
when caught up in the
inevitable storms of daily life.
The superior person has the ability to
continue talking to himself in a positive
and optimistic way,
keeping his mind calm and clear
and completely under control.
The mature personality is
more relaxed and aware,
and capable of interpreting
events more realistically
and less emotionally than
is the immature personality.
As a result, the mature person
exerts a far greater sense
of control and influence
over his environment
and is far less likely to be
angry or upset or distracted.
As the Buddhists say, "The immature person
practices detachment.
And though they're concerned about things,
they don't get excited,
they just stay calm."
Starting today, resolve
to think like an optimist,
no matter what happens.
Look for the good in every situation.
Look for a lesson that you can learn
when you have a failure or a set back.
You may not be able to control events,
but you can control the
way you react to them,
and in doing that, you
control your whole life.
- [Robin] How do you really take a bad day
and restructure it,
so that you can actually turn
it into something valuable?
And so I'm going to share with you,
the five P's of turning a bad day
into a valuable day, and even an epic day.
And I'm going to dial
right into the first one,
which is Perspective.
Perspective is a word
that seems very simple
but I think it's very powerful.
It's very easy to get
seduced into making something small,
a lot larger than it is.
And perspective simply reminds us
to go to 50,000 feet on a bad day,
and count our blessings.
Perspective simply reminds us
that things could be a lot worse.
Perspective on a bad day,
is simply understanding
that we live in a world where
half the world's population
lives on less than $2.50 a day.
Perspective on a bad day,
is reminding yourself
of that Persian proverb, of which says,
"I curse the fact I had no shoes,
until I saw the man who had no feet."
Perspective is such a powerful word.
Here's a great question on a bad day,
to bring on some perspective.
Has anyone died here?
So perspective is something
I really want you to think
about, and on a bad day,
it will actually allow you
to turn the lead into gold
and really pivot.
Which brings me to the second P,
of turning a bad day, into a great day,
and it's Pivot.
And here's the question
to really help you pivot.
W T O H: What's The Opportunity Here?
So you're having a bad day,
maybe you had a fight with someone,
maybe you lost a big sale,
maybe someone cut you off in traffic,
and then you didn't get
your favorite lunch,
and then you missed getting
into Soul Cycle Class.
And then you had a
difficulty on the way home,
so let's say that's happening.
You simply run the W T O H question,
which will allow you to pivot.
W T O H: What's The Opportunity Here?
See there's great power in a question.
And it allows your brain
to hunt for something good.
And so how do you pivot?
You ask yourself: What's
The Opportunity Here?
You have a fight with someone,
let's say one of your family members,
you say, "What's the opportunity here?"
Well, your brain then starts
to look for the opportunity,
which is, I can learn how
to communicate better.
Or this is an opportunity
for me to show forgiveness
and grow in my personal bravery.
This is an opportunity
for me to understand
my family member better.
It's a great and powerful question.
Which brings me to my third P,
in turning a bad day into a great day,
and it's really Pharmacy.
The third P is Pharmacy,
and that's all about moving.
When I have a difficult day,
here's one of the first things I do,
I will get on my mountain bike
and I will ride like
a bat out of wherever,
through the forest, and that
releases dopamine in my brain,
which is the neurotransmitter
of inspiration.
And that releases serotonin, moving,
ride on the bicycle,
it releases serotonin,
which is the pleasure neurotransmitter.
And it cuts down on my cortisol,
which is the fear hormone.
So just simply going for
a mountain bike ride,
or going for a swim,
or getting into yoga class,
or something as simple
as going for a walk,
or maybe even doing jumping
jacks when no one's looking,
will create a pharmacy of
mastery within your brain,
which will affect your psychology,
your neurobiology, and your interior life,
which makes you feel just a lot better.
You know that.
After a workout, you always
feel different than you did
before you went into the workout.
And related to the pharmacy of mastery,
is something that I have
counted on for years,
when I've had good seasons,
when I've had challenging
seasons of my life,
massage.
I call it the two massage protocol:
two massages every single week,
it moves your lymph, it moves your blood,
which oxygenates your system,
it reduces toxicity, you
feel a whole lot better.
Which brings me to the fourth P,
in turning a bad day
into a great day: Pages.
You know I love journaling,
and for hundreds and hundreds of years,
people who have gone through difficulty,
people who are experiencing
calamity and chaos,
open a journal
turn to a fresh white page,
and pour their pain or
pour their confusion,
pour their frustration,
out onto that page.
It does something so powerful.
It allows for a profound release
of what you're experiencing,
out onto the written page.
Here's the key, if you will repress
and suppress your feelings,
of anger, of sadness, of disappointment,
all of those lower energy feelings,
if you keep them inside,
they not only build up toxicity,
and they build up
resentment and frustration,
but those are the very things
that lead to inflammation,
that create dis-ease.
And so what I'm sharing with you,
with great love and respect,
is really very potent.
Pages, the fourth four
of turning a bad day
into a great day.
Pull out your journal and
write what you're feeling
onto a fresh, crisp, written page.
Which brings me to my fifth and final P,
in the five P's of turning
a bad day into a great day,
the Planet.
Now you're saying, "Robin, what
are you talking about here?"
Well, nature.
Nature is life's sweet recovery method.
Going for a walk in the woods,
or walking on a beach and
getting next to the ocean,
or if you live near a
desert, getting out there.
If you're blessed to
live by the mountains,
you know what I'm talking about.
But when you go out to
nature, it grounds you.
When you connect with
the planet, again nature,
what does it do?
It gives you that recovery method
so you actually breathe in the fresh air,
but it reminds you,
you are part of something so
much bigger than yourself.
And maybe your bad day,
is taking you to a better place.
You know, you've heard that old idea,
but life doesn't really happen to you,
life really happens for you.
And there is this incredible
intelligence to life,
we don't understand it.
Look, you and I are humans, we resist it.
But what if the thing you see as bad,
is just your false belief
system, judging it as bad.
We all know this.
The things that we see as bad,
over time, turned out to be blessings.
And so everything is
really happening for you,
for your best interests.
It's taking you to a better place,
it's making you stronger,
it's teaching you great
lessons, often we resist it,
but it all comes for our good.
So those are the five
P's to take a bad day
and really transmute it into a great day.
Definitely do these five,
because these are all muscles,
and like anything, the more you practice,
the stronger and more
fluent you're going to get.
And if you keep on practicing,
you are going to get to a place
where everyone else is feeling,
"Oh, I've gone through this
difficulty, it's a bad day,"
and you're going to see it as possibility
and you're going to be masterful
at turning the difficulty
into opportunity.
Hope I've been of service,
I'll talk to you soon.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know, what did you think?
What did you learn from this video,
that you're going to
apply immediately somehow
to your life or to your business?
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm really excited to hear from you.
And if you leave a comment
within the first few hours
of this video going live,
you might win one of our two daily prizes.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Danijel and Aleksandra,
thank you guys so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, and posted an awesome
five star review on Amazon.
I really really really appreciate it,
I'm so glad the book had
an impact on your life.
And thank you so much for
sharing and supporting me.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
much love.
I'll see you soon.
(airplane sound)
- [Girl] Look, I can be a shark.
Now, my whole house is great.
I can do anything good.
I like my school.
I like anything.
I like my dad, I like my cousins.
I like my aunts, I like my Allisons.
I like my mom, I like my sisters,
I like my dad,
(crying)
I like my hair, I like my haircuts.
I like my pajamas, I like my stuff.
I like my room.
I like my whole house.
(claps)
My whole house is great.
I can do anything good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can do anything, good.
Better than anyone.
- And now, you might
also have this objection
over this thought, that
goes something like this,
"Well, Leo, okay positive thinking.
I hear you, it sounds nice.
But isn't positive thinking
actually dangerous?
I mean, I'm a realist.
Isn't it better to be a realist in life?
Rather than to be this
starry eyed optimist?
And approach everything optimistically?
Isn't realism the best approach?
I mean, what if you're optimistic
and then you're all about optimism,
that you have all those goals and dreams
and the outcomes that
you set for yourself,
all those just come crashing down when it
comes and kind of collides with reality?
What if you're cheerful
and you're telling yourself
to be all happy, and then
someone close to you dies,
and then you're not able to maintain that?
What happens then Leo?
Isn't that reckless? Isn't that dangerous?
Aren't you setting yourself up for pain?"
And the answer is this:
you are setting yourself up for pain,
if what you're doing is
you're setting these hard expectations,
and you're very attached to the outcome.
But it doesn't have to be that way.
Right? See, this where discounters
and naysayers of positive thinking,
will get it wrong.
Is they'll say, "Well positive thinking,
that's going to set me up for failure.
That's going to set up to disappointment."
The problem is, they're being positive,
and they're telling their
self, "Well, I'm positive,
and I need the outcome to be positive.
And if it's not positive, then
everything's going to Hell."
But see, true positive thinking is like
be more relaxed, be more chill,
be outcome detached.
You're a positive thinker,
you're thinking positive
about the situation,
that doesn't mean that the
situation won't turn bad.
That doesn't mean that you
can foretell the future
and you can get everything that you want
to happen in your life,
to happen in the way that you want it;
never going to happen.
On the contrary, it means
that you're going to have
ups and downs, you're going to
have things unexpectedly happen.
You might have some sort of lofty ambition
or goal for your business,
and then it comes crashing down,
and it, you know, the
market comes and it crashes,
and your business crashes with it.
Or maybe you have some nice expectations
and you're thinking very
positive about your relationship
and then your relationship
ends in a divorce.
That could happen.
So I'm not saying you can
necessarily prevent that
in all situations.
But the idea here is that,
if you're a positive thinker,
you remain positive, and
you're not attached to it.
See if you're a realist or a pessimist,
then actually what you're
doing is you're like,
"Okay, if I'm thinking positive,
then I need it to actually pan out.
I need it to be positive all the time."
And of course that's not going to work.
That's a neurotic way of
doing positive thinking.
True positive thinking is
like being cool and chill
and is like, "You know
what, if it happens, good.
And if it doesn't happen,
you know, still good."
Heads I win, tails I win,
that's what a true
positive attitude is about.
Alright so, I'm going to wrap it up here.
This is what cultivating
a positive attitude means.
It's really about acceptance.
You have to accept.
What do you have to accept?
One: you have to accept
the present moment,
as it is, completely inevitable.
Number two: you have to accept that worry
is completely useless
and of no value to you.
Number three: you have to
accept that cheerfulness
is the best strategy to
go through life with.
And you have to now
strive to live up to that.
Right, I know it's hard,
this doesn't mean it's easy,
It's going to be very hard.
But, if you're like me,
then you see the longterm potential here.
I mean, how awesome would it be
to develop yourself internally?
So that you could have a true
positive attitude about life?
So that no matter what happens to you,
you can remain cheerful,
so that you're not worrying,
and you're not feeling
like you have to worry
because you know that the
worry is not helping you.
And that you're in the present moment
and you accept the moment as it is.
If you can achieve all those things,
then you've basically
accomplished nirvana;
you've got Heaven on Earth,
like nothing can hurt
you, you're untouchable.
So this is a very powerful
goal to set for yourself,
is to cultivate this attitude
over the months and the years,
as you're growing yourself
and you're doing other stuff,
try to move you way and inch your way up,
to having a true positive
attitude about life.
- [Wengie] One thing that I've found,
like really really hard about optimism,
is that you can't expect to become
an optimistic person
overnight, it does not happen.
It's probably taken me like five years
of constant practicing to
become an optimistic person,
or someone that can see
the bright side of things.
And when I'm in a bad mood or something,
I tend to go back to my old habits
and think really negatively.
But in general, it gets
easier and easier to,
I guess, have a better
perspective on things,
as you practice.
So for those of you guys
wondering why it's so hard
to be optimistic, don't need to wonder,
it is really really hard,
especially if it doesn't come naturally,
but I know that you can be an
optimistic person if you try.
So I'm going to be showing some of my tips
that I have used to help me.
And I believe everyone is born with
sort of a natural level of happiness,
and there have been
scientific research studies
that have been done,
that everyone comes with
a baseline of happiness.
And whatever that is for you,
that is kind of where
you naturally will sit.
So if you're born like someone
that isn't naturally happy,
you have a lot more work to do,
and you need a little bit more practice
but there's nothing wrong with you.
And if you're born a super happy person,
then you don't really
need to try very hard
to be optimistic.
And if you are born
someone that, you know,
wasn't born super duper like
happy go lucky kind of person,
you may look around and see these people
always being so cheerful and bubbly,
and wonder, how the Hell did they do it?
Well, I believe they may
have been born with it.
But you know, I don't
know, it's just science.
So, I guess for those of you
that have a baseline level
that isn't as high,
you just need to switch the
way you think about things.
And I think this is
something I've been noticing
really really like obviously lately.
Like, with any given situation,
there's always multiple
ways to look at it.
Like if you get into a car accident,
you can either feel like, you know,
it's the worst thing that happened today.
And you could also think,
this is the luckiest day of my life
because I'm still alive
after having a car accident.
So a car accident can either
be super duper negative to you,
or it can be like, oh my God, I'm alive.
I better live my life better.
So you can see how something
so tragic and terrible
can have two sides of
the coin, pretty easily.
Like I can imagine someone
feeling both feelings.
And you'll probably know
someone in your life,
that will experience
both of these feelings.
So I guess when you look at
any situation objectively,
it's kind of a choice.
It's your choice to decide
what any given situation means to you,
and that is your decision to make,
and no one else can force you to think
like it's a negative situation,
and no one else can force you
to think it's a positive situation.
I guess becoming an optimistic person
means making that choice in your life,
and then sticking to it,
and being really aware of the
thoughts going in your head,
and how you think, etc.
Because someone can get cancer,
and they can have two different reactions.
One person may take it as
it's their chance to do
everything that they wanted to do,
and help people.
And one may feel like a victim
and think like it's the worst thing.
Why did this happen to me?
And then spend the rest of their days,
mulling over and being really grumpy.
It's your choice, really.
And I know I'm using
really extreme examples,
like accidents and cancer,
but it's these extreme examples
that can really show you
the glaring difference
between how people think.
And even though
you don't automatically
think optimistically,
it doesn't mean you can't do it over time.
So I always catch myself
doing things like this,
if I catch myself thinking negative,
I will stop, breathe,
and then try and rethink
about the situation again.
And then when you do that,
that process becomes easier,
much like lifting weights.
At first, lifting you know heavy weights,
would be like really hard.
But if you practice every single day
and then just lift a little
bit more every single day,
you will actually get really good at it.
And I don't know why I always
use weights as an example,
but I don't know, the gym is just my
go to example for things,
I have no idea why.
But yeah, so whatever
situation you're in right now,
and you're feeling really down about it,
I want you to sit down
with a piece of paper,
or even in your mind,
it really depends on which
way is easier for you,
and to think of all the different ways
someone can think of that situation.
You don't have to put yourself
in that situation personally yet.
Pretend you have five different friends,
how would each of them
think about this situation?
And then you can list out all the ways
I could think about it differently,
and that will really open your eyes
on the amount of ways that you
can think about it yourself.
And then you can choose
the one that will help you
the best.
Because at the end of the day,
whatever you think about the situation
will determine what your future can be.
Someone that thinks positively
of a really bad situation
can end up being you know,
the person that helps many other people
in the same situation
through sharing their story,
opening a charity, or
doing volunteer work.
And then the other very same person
can affect their future
by playing the victim
and then spending the rest of their time
making all their friends miserable
by dragging them into their sad story.